In today's video,
we're going to take a look
at the relationship
between dry ice and Coke,
how they react,
and how big
of a reaction we can get.
[Music]
You've probably seen
some cool videos,
or played around
with the reaction
between Diet Coke and Mentos.
This is a cool
little experiment.
The mint surface on these Mentos
has tons of tiny tiny points
that work as nucleation sites
inside of the soda.
The nucleation sites
pull the carbon dioxide
out of the soda
where it's dissolved,
and it suddenly increases
in size massively erupting up
out of the bottle.
Lots of people have done
experiments with this,
and it's really fun
to try at home as
long as you're safe about it.
Well, we want to
try something else,
and that's the relationship
between these carbonated sodas
and dry ice.
The dry ice can act much
the same as the Mentos with lots
of tiny little nucleation sites.
It pulls carbon dioxide
out of the soda quickly,
with the added benefit
that the dry ice
itself starts to sublimate,
and that expands as well,
adding even more carbon dioxide
into the mixture.
Hopefully, giving us
an even bigger reaction.
Here's the basic idea.
We're going to see
what it takes to get
the best reaction
between dry ice and Coke,
and then we're going to try
and scale that up
to something really impressive.
Here we go.
We're going to do side-by-side
tests of Coke Zero, Diet Coke,
and regular Coke.
One at a time though.
Here goes Coke Zero
with 3 Mentos.
[Music]
Right about there, I'd say.
Not bad.
Decent little reaction.
There it goes.
Little mushroom fountain.
That's fine if it
goes out of screen,
it's just to show
it reacting is the fun part.
First was Coke Zero,
now is Diet Coke.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
It may be went just
a smidge higher,
but the most part, the Diet Coke
and the Coke Zero reacted
almost exactly the same way.
[Music]
I would call that a noticeably
smaller reaction.
The Coke Zero and the diet Coke
both got to about here.
The regular Coke, I'd say,
only six to eight inches
above the bottle.
[Music]
We got a pretty good launch,
but of course, we want more
out of it than that.
So, this time,
we're going to see
what happens if we
constrict the opening
a little bit more.
This funnel here has
a much smaller opening
on it than our Coke bottle.
So we're going to try
and attach the funnel on
to the top of the Coke bottle,
and then drop
the Mentos in afterward.
Now this is going to be
a little bit tricky.
So here's my thought.
We'll have three Mentos taped
together just on the outside.
That tape will be attached
to a piece of string,
which will come up
through the funnel,
and then we can let go,
and that should drop
the Mentos down in.
That point, shooting
our little geyser up
through our much
constricted funnel nozzle.
[Music]
The drop.
3, oh-- 1.
That probably went
eight to ten feet up in the air.
This little nozzle here,
the opening is probably
1/5 to 1/8 the area
of the regular
Coke bottle opening.
So it does have
to go a lot faster,
and when it's going faster,
it goes a lot higher.
Let's move onto dry ice.
Now, we're moving onto dry ice,
and we're going to do
two little test.
We're going to do single lumps
that are just barely small
that they can fit through
the nozzle of the bottle,
and then we're going to try
a crushing up a bunch
of dry ice powder,
and dropping that in as well.
So first up, single lumps.
Coke Zero and single
lump of dry ice.
Here it goes.
[Music]
A very quick foamy reaction in
this state with a single lump.
It wasn't more volume,
and it didn't go higher than it
did with the three Mentos,
but we still,
as you saw,
got a very quick reaction.
Same thing.
Diet Coke.
[Music]
Once again, quick reaction,
lots of volume.
A lot of soda was pushed out,
but it didn't go as high as it
did with the Mentos.
It wasn't as fast.
All right, regular Coke,
dry ice, single lump.
[Music]
As expected.
I got a lot more of the smell
of the Coca-Cola
with the regular,
as opposed to either
of the diet versions.
And I think we actually lost
more total volume
with the dry ice.
It just took longer.
All right, let's try
powdered dry ice.
[Music]
My goal with the powder dry ice
is to have approximately
the same volume as three Mentos.
So I think that should give
us the best comparison
of the reactions.
I'm going to take the powdered
dry ice from this funnel,
and pour it down through
this funnel into the soda.
We'll see what kind
of reaction we get.
[Music]
It didn't sink.
Oh, it didn't all go in either.
It got frozen.
All right, we're going to try
adding a little bit more.
Some of it didn't quite
make it through.
The funnel got a little clogged.
Funnel likes to get
a little bit clogged.
So this is kind of interesting.
We're getting a very
very quick reaction
with the dust with the really
fine powdered stuff.
It's actually reacting
so quickly that it
just hits the surface,
and then there's so
much bubbles and foam
that the rest of the ice powder
isn't actually sinking
into the cola.
So with these larger pieces,
we're getting more
of a reaction.
We just have to be able
to get them all in at once.
So I'm going to try going more
of those slightly larger pieces
into this bottle,
and pouring it in this one
without any of the small stuff
to cause foam that will stop it.
We've got a bunch
of pebble sized pieces
of dry ice, and hopefully,
those will flow in
and actually sink a little bit.
Here it goes.
[Music]
Yeah, kind of like that.
That was a much faster reaction.
Still didn't have a ton
of sinking so I don't think
our height was any better
than with the Mentos,
but the speed of the reaction
was quite impressive.
That got me...
This is one of the reasons
we like using Diet Coke,
is it doesn't have sugar in it
so it doesn't get sticky
when you get coated in it.
Still gonna want to wash,
but I won't be
sticky until then.
I actually think
that from here,
we just want to scale this up.
I want to go big,
and rather than using one
of these little Coke bottles,
we're going way up.
We're gonna use
a 5 gallon bucket.
For this larger bucket,
we're going to use
our larger funnel
that still has a pretty
small opening right there.
So here's the plan.
Much like with our mementos
that we dropped into the coke
through the funnel
on the string,
we are going to attach
our dry ice to a mesh surface.
We're going to sort of
make a bag out of it.
The bag will be suspended
underneath the lid,
and we're going
to lower it all down.
We're going to clip this lid on.
They're already be
several gallons of
Coca-Cola inside this.
I think we're gonna
use the Diet Coke.
I like the reaction of that one.
So, Diet Coke, several gallons.
Dry ice, 10 pounds at least.
Whatever we can fit in
between the Coke
and the surface.
We're going to seal this down.
We're going to actually
add some additional tape
to make sure it's really strong,
and we're going to let go
of the string, and hopefully,
we will get an almighty launched
through the sky.
[Music]
Up to where the dry ice
is will be full of Coke,
and then, by letting go
of the strings,
all of that dry ice will drop
down into the Coke all at once.
Hopefully, we get just
an absolutely insane reaction.
Okay, here we go.
Whole lot of Diet Coke.
Hopefully, we don't lose too
much of the fizz by pouring it
into this separate bucket.
This is the last we're
gonna able to pour in
before it's too high up.
[Music]
Okay, I'm ready when you are.
I'm ready.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
Well, in terms of volume...
We had a lot.
[Music]
I'm going to tip it.
It's a little strong
for the bucket seal.
I think I can get another
another shot out of this.
[Music]
That's a weird kind
of Coca-Cola gun right there.
Refill a little bit,
put another chunk
of dry ice into that.
[Music]
I'm trying this again.
Might help the lid
stay on better.
Might just make it louder
when the lid pops off.
[Music]
There's the louder
when the bucket pops open.
That was, thinking might happen.
[Music]
And that wire mesh,
which I'm sure
is so healthy.
[Music]
Oh, it's leaking.
Oh, it popped.
Definitely leaked
before popping.
[Music]
Slushy.
Guys, that's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top is going
to take you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box shows you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
you'll be subscribed
to the channel.
That way, you never gonna miss
out on one of our cool videos.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.